Hola de nuevo, bueno parece que fue muy abrumador
todo lo de Chuck Norris que hice en el video
pasado, así que haré algo diferente.
Intentemos simplificar algunas otras expresiones
y bueno, veremos que estamos aplicando ideas
que ya conocemos, ideas con las que ya estamos
muy familiarizados.
Digamos que yo quiero simplificar la expresión
2 por "3x" más 5, esto... esto literalmente...
esto es lo mismo que "3x" más 5 más otro "3x" más 5.
Es lo que quiere decir, 2 por "3x" más 5.
¿Y esto a qué es igual?
Esto es lo mismo, lo podemos escribir como,
como dos veces "3x" entonces,
2 por "3x" más dos veces el 5, así que aquí es...
aquí es éste dos veces,
dos veces el 5, entonces más 2 por 5.
Y tal vez te estés preguntando, y bueno ,
¿ésta será la propiedad distributiva?
Estamos distribuyendo el 2 sobre el "3x" más
"x" y en efecto, yo te diría que sí, así es.
La razón por la que estoy haciendo esto es
principalmente porque quiero que veas que
eso es la propiedad distributiva, ya lo sabes,
pero bueno, en fin...
Vamos a simplificar esto cuando multiplicamos
el 2 por el "3x", entonces obtienes "6x", ajá.
Aquí es, esto es igual a "6x" y multiplicas
el 2 por el 5 y obtienes 10, entonces más 10.
Y ahora intentemos, intentemos algo más.
Ahora una vez más estas son cosas que tú
ya sabes, digamos...
digamos que yo tengo 7 por "3y"...
"3y" menos 5 y esto menos... menos 2 por 10
más digamos...
¿qué te gusta?...
"4y"...
entonces más "4y".
Veamos si podemos simplificar esto, trabajemos...
trabajemos con primero este lado de la expresión.
Aquí tenemos 7 por "3y" menos 5, simplemente...
simplemente tenemos que distribuir el 7 sobre
esto, así es "21y" menos... menos...
ten cuidado con el signo aquí, aquí tenemos...
estamos multiplicando no por 5, sino por -5
y eso es -35... -35 y ya quedó este lado,
ahora vamos con el lado derecho, tal vez tú...
tú quieres hacer el 2 por 10 y 2 por "4y",
luego restarlos.
Si lo haces distribuyendo el signo menos si
va a funcionar, pero a mi gusto, me gusta
pensar en esto como el -2, lo voy a distribuir,
tenemos -2 por 10, luego -2 por "4y",
así es que lo que vamos a hacer aquí es...
es -2 por 10, tenemos...
esto es igual a -20...
-20 luego -2 por "4y" será igual a "-8y",
ajá, entonces aquí esto es igual a "-8y".
Y ya, ya terminamos, eso fue todo... no aún no,
porque podemos sumar términos semejantes.
No podemos sumar el "21y" y el -35, porque
no son semejantes,
así que bueno, tenemos aquí "21y" y tenemos el "-8y"...
Veamos aquí, sería entonces...
aquí tenemos "21y", restamos -8,
le restamos este -8 y nos queda...
a 21 le quito 8, eso es 13, nos queda entonces "13y"...
"21y" menos "8y" es "13y".
Luego...
luego tengo yo el -35 y el -20,
aquí este lo pongo en otro color, aquí es -35 y -20,
eso se simplifica a -55
y todo esto usando la propiedad distributiva y acomodando términos semejantes llegamos a "13y"
menos 55, es la respuesta final.